EIGHT G G" ARE JOINING IN.
>> Chris: JOHN TAVARES.
NYLANDER HAS GOT A STEP TO THE
HAS BACK.
DERMOTT SENDS IT WIDE.
SIMMONDS TRIED TO PLAY IT IN
FRFR ALIVE.
GOOD PLAY BY SPEZZA.
SPEZZA IS GOING BEHIND WITH THAT
NHL GAME TONIGHT.
CENTREED IN FRONT.
AUSTON
INSTEAD MATTHEWS LEFT IN ALONE.
IF YOU LOOK AT THE.
HIS SHOT STEERED AWAY BY
CAMPBELL.
FED BACK TO MACKINNON AS ENTER.
THE GROUP COMING BACK.
YOU HAVERADO HAS HAD MORE
OFFENSIVE-ZONE TIME IN THE GAME.
ITIT GOING.. A KNUCKLER.
OH, NYLANDER.
TAVARES WAS UP-ENDED THERE IN A
PILEUP WITH SAVE,
BUT TAVARES SAYS HE HAS DONE S
ALEX KERFOOT.
THIS LINE PLUS THREE ON THE
NIGHTS AS WE START THE THIRDD IE
WARMUP.
MATTHEWS AND MARNER THROW BLIND
PASSES TO EACH OTHER THE LASAS
KERFOOT UNABLE TO CORAL THAT.
MACKINNON TOOK A SWIPE ATERE IS
MATTHEWS.
GOOD LITTLE MOVE., SCORE
GOT THE SPEED TO THE OUTSIAS BEY
SINCE JOINING THE
ANOTHER GUY WHO IS SHOWING LIFES
LANDESKOG.
HE WILL LEAVE IT FOR K THAT ONEN
AND LAY FLAT A LITTLE BIT TOO